[Music]
hey marshal the f5 say it like you mean
it go
oh it's going to be this time do you
guys see look I wasn't cut on that with
that much my shirt
say big like this let me share those
slides on my phone fight okay so
sometimes you get it cut well sometimes
your cutting angle is off what if I
can't see you have to pick trusty is the
is probably the most effective it is it
looks better
yeah we just come up you cut off the
neck
so when you're doing these you have too
much to do too much on the hand they
died to stop okay so jump over here you
see it might be a book you you see but
okay but it's not really a page not
gonna baby move back
okay I keep that moving right takes some
that you're doing full pull you can see
the spines up okay whatever you want to
do
whoa
it's a save up either I can cook you
look like you have to use that angle
modulation he spoke this way okay so
what do you so on like that seems going
forward it's good to be more friction on
the night a chance to series one forward
one oppression on tonight dick during
the same move he's going forward well
I've got less pressure on the night it's
not gonna buy anything she's gonna bite
that
hence the phrase it's not all anything
okay so if I come over here all right oh
maybe Big Boss do you think by Kevin
chasing the cutting edge
it's a skill you can't learn it's not a
technique so he's going I'm just happy
to do this and I think having you task
yourself with this should you get more
rest
identifying what the shoulder looks like
Monday hip looks like he ordered exam so
you move your move already
it's coming from the right good you do
to recognize that too you see you have
to respond to the bottom of the body and
you already change the active change
so don't not do your drill you don't
always want to bite on the knife armor
what is the drill you have to fight on
the knife phone you can see not going
like this gentleman like this you don't
have a job every time every time
now that's the first drill so you get
used to this you can see it okay but it
there you go
so I'm doing that drill whoa hey he will
come in your chosen won't dirty guns
right or maybe another nice pass between
I don't know I don't know which would be
right
I don't know well I don't get to this
stage I don't know but I don't have to
have it I'm really here we go
I'm reading I'm feeling you see are you
wanting control
[Music]
really
breathe
[Music]
come on
again and we destroy I okay so I'm not
here right but you're not moment do you
understand Joe I can't go like this
not here Palace you see that you get
maybe I get you here you pulled it up
and book a oh I have a chicken do you
understand so on the other one right
what's you guys you're sure she's gotta
get into town Joe and that's if we do
put you I good hope you come
what's a liliani listen do you
understand what meeting that I don't ask
I didn't count for you in the midst of
your time you leave you so much balance
do you get it so they got the guy goes
[Music]
right
they're always get into it
people who counter boom right and people
stronger flow and people faster you get
it but what you have to do instead is
take the balance don't stand in front of
them
okay go you know that and what did you
do you just wait and throw it through
yet right
what is feeling required I'm doing
something well who's doing the something
yeah okay so I don't go up there and
grab we're not taking the opening okay
so I'm going to go it's fine why I see
what you see I just need you beat like
eight reps if you're exhausted okay did
you see something worth noting we just
raised my eyes they stopped okay did you
okay
so you can use the knife to get to do
the Kazushi do you see that ah are you
cut and take with the knife did you feel
that so somebody over here this he's
going I got here is push a piece off the
road path but that would bring him back
up you see again so is introduced the
line to keep the position the other side
better let me see
what would you call that
wait what you reading I'm reading it
watch my watch try to see this I've
already bought oh okay here's something
that looks like the other one how do you
see but why isn't it first or something
push push push what let me know there's
nothing to push
[Music]
get stuck out here all the time
so you gotta be done the second one
you're gonna lose it - lets all the way
down slow way down
whoa bye clip you see rock Lucas gonna
standardize so I'm here right
I'm not gonna call this side and use the
look whoa when I touch that's all I need
you see that all men do the exact same
thing I'm gonna cut this pull hold on
you guys yes
for me okay so yeah and forget the
footwork just get the adhesion and I
want to see it take and these two sets
but I'm not cutting down on her arm
I'm not cutting down one arm and they're
not walking from your bracelet bracelet
bracelet okay but it
okay go please tell the way I just want
you to understand that and as you're yet
you start milking it where you start
doing the move and you're supposed to do
okay
it's I'm trying to show you you could do
the opposite of what you think you're
supposed to do and you don't still work
okay it actually works but who knows why
no that's right so you can do I keep the
more aggressive and resisted the person
is the more words he generates more
friction at the contact point so we do
pull it away from me there's more
friction and the contact point okay so
that's not that therefore there's no
reason for you to do it before I do it
as you can you get it so just come in
with your movement you see and then make
sure as I get it you're not can you not
foot down and all you
but it said you get wool okay get rid of
the knife just go slow the sudden weight
do it now if you're pushing out on this
push out on that he brings his arm
anything okay it's straight
it is gonna stay straight it's misty
straight
we're not fighting but stay straight
okay and I find that young equivalent
and then just whinnies I don't doesn't
matter what you think okay
so when you get here I can want you to
do stuff with the white when you know
your arm you see my hat anyway so if you
gonna try different things okay
some of them are armed
gon be us hard
but try to see I want to distinguish
between is fully by but not move your
feet yes there's a Tunisian but there's
a topical component - okay so you're
like you know your setup but okay but
it's harder to be on
you can start over the first one started
you see the ledge okay there's my left
anything open it open it that's that's
our children won't move no forget it
he's moving he's gonna move but he feels
that he's gonna open up it once again
try
I'm a movie with that movie instead
what are you doing you push it down so
then that would mean you're what
yeah yeah do you get it so here's the
hook okay and this is the hook that's
what you're doing
you feel that but this was going like
OPR
[Music]
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh do you understand
this is what's gonna happen what if you
have an adhesion that can't happen this
is still going to happen that's what
that's why it's used here on the second
five pounder because he never really
regain his balance he's through it
anyways that's what people do okay you
get it so when you don't keep their
balance or don't take their balance
you're gonna give them back the
advantage okay so when we're doing this
drill and some you this rule that is all
died and he goes and you always make him
move a little further than he wants to
you understand and a little bit to this
way then you wanted to you get it do you
guys understand that
okay let's try the drill without the
night
you Zoey
yeah
okay
[Music]
Oh
oh here we go
boom push you push here did you that's a
big person second yes okay